Hi, welcome to this my third session on
timing the market. Markets reflect the
economy, right? At least that's a
conventional wisdom. What happens to
interest rates, what happens to the
economy should ultimately play out in
markets. And there are people who take
this insight which is a logical one and
build on and say if I can forecast where
interest rates are going or what the
economy is doing, I should be able to
forecast markets, right? And the answer
they expect usually is sure. Yeah. In
this session, we're going to look at the
link between fundamentals, macro
fundamentals in the market and whether
you can use that linkage to actually
make money on that on those
relationships.
Ultimately, many of the measures we use
to time markets are mind mean reversion
measures. What does that mean? We assume
things revert back to the way they used
to be. In the context of stocks and
bonds, here's how they play up. In the
stock market, we look at PE ratios, the
multiple of earnings stocks trade at.
And we look at what stocks are trading
at as a multiple of earnings today
relative to history. And if this number,
the number they're trading at today is
much higher, we argue stocks are
overpriced. If interest rates today are
much lower than they used to be, we
argue that they're going to go up.
Implicit in both is the assumption that
things revert back to the way they used
to be. We'll talk about when that
assumption breaks down, but it's a
pretty reasonable one, right? So, let's
take US equities and look at PE ratios
going back to 1960.
So, what I've looked at is price, the
level of the index divide by the
trailing earnings for the index. What
does that mean? On December 31st of each
year, I don't know what the earnings
will be through December 31st. I note
only only through September 30th or the
third quarter of the year. I'm taking
the trailing earnings and I've graphed
out the P ratio. I've also taken the
historical P ratio and this is pure
statistics. Don't read more than you
should into it. And looked at the 75th
percentile and the 25th percentile, the
third and the first quartile. The 75th
percentile is 19.9. That's a PE ratio of
about 20. And the 25th percentile is a
PE ratio of about 14.5. You're saying so
what if you're a believer in mean
reversion and you looked at the PE ratio
in 2024 which is about the PE ratio is
about 23 your argument will be stocks
are overpriced why because they're much
higher than they should be the PE ratio
is much higher than the 75th percentile
in contrast you go back to 2011 or much
of the 1970s
your argument is stocks are underpriced
the P ratio is much lower than the 25th
percentile and already you can see the
seeds of weakness in these approaches.
In hindsight, of course, it looks like a
great strategy. In the 1970s, if you'd
bought stocks in 1972, which is when
they first dropped below the 25th
percentile, you'd have spent an entire
decade in the darkness. But that's the
basis for the PE ratio. And it's a and
since the PE ratio is so widely talked
about, it should come as no surprise
that there have been modifications of
that traditional PE ratio. When you
divide the level of the index today by
the earnings in the most recent year,
one of the problems you run into is
because earnings are cyclical. They're
volatile. They're up in boom years, down
in bust years. There are people who say
rather than look at last year's
earnings, we should look at earnings
over a longer period. That's called a
normalized PE. We take the price today
and divide by the average earnings for
the last 10 years. But when you bring in
the earnings over the last 10 years, you
bring in another wild card which is if
there's inflation, earnings from 10
years ago and earnings today are not
directly comparable. So here's what you
can do. You can take the earnings from
10 years ago adjusted for inflation. And
when you do that, you've gone from
normalized PE to what's called the
Schiller PE. The Schiller PE is a
normalized inflation adjusted earnings.
And the argument is it's a much better
measure of the PE ratio because it
smooths things out and gives you a
better perspective. As you can see in
this graph, I think too much is made of
it. For the most part, the three
versions of PE ratios move together.
Regular PE, normalized P, and Schiller
PE. And guess what? All of them at the
end of 2024 would have said stocks are
overpriced because the PE ratio today is
higher than it's been historically.
But key here to remember is when you say
higher than it's been historically is
you're drawing drawing on the assumption
that things revert back to the way they
used to be. That's with stocks. Let's
look at interest rates. This is a graph
of the T-bond rate, the 10-year T- bond
rate going back to 1927.
Again, if you take this graph, you can
draw the 90th, the 75th, the the 25th,
and the 10th percentile. You're going to
get a range on rates and there will be
periods where interest rates are below
that range. And here again, mean
reversion kicks in. If interest rates
are higher than they've been
historically, let's say the 90th
percentile is 5%. And you're at 7%, the
argument is rates are going to are more
likely to come down. If rates are lower
than they were historically, let's say
they're 2%, the historical historically
the 25th percentile is closer to 4%. The
argument might be rates are too low,
they've got to go up. And here again,
the weaknesses kind of kick through,
right? In the last decade, for instance,
you'd have been out of the entire bond
market with this view because rates
dropped below historic norms and they
stayed lower. Now, of course, the reason
they stayed lower is there were
structural shifts in the economy that
kept rates low. And of course, for
conspiracy-minded people, the Fed kept
rates low. But whatever the reason, just
because rates are lower or higher than
expected doesn't mean that they will
move back to the norm at least in the
near term. So with both stocks and
bonds, there is this assumption of mean
reversion. So that's one way to think
about market timing is to draw on mean
reversion. Assume things will revert.
and a surprisingly large number of
market dimemers. That's the basis for
their argument that stocks are expensive
or cheap is comparing P ratios today to
P ratios historically or interest rates
today to interest rates historically.
A slightly deeper way of thinking about
market timing is say look ultimately
what you see in the market has be a
reflection of what's happening in the
economy. What's happening to interest
rates, inflation, GDP growth and over
time there have been rules of thumb that
have been developed that claim to tell
you what's going to happen to stocks
based on what happens to those
fundamentals. I've heard people argue
that the best time to buy stocks is when
interest rates are dropping
when in or when the long-term interest
rates are really low or when the yield
curve is upward sloping. Basically, what
you're capturing there is are long-term
rates much higher than short-term rates
or when the economy is strong. Now,
intuitively, all those things seem to
make sense, right? When interest rates
are low, of course, prices should be
higher. When GDP growth is strong,
earnings growth should also be stronger.
But to see how noisy these for these
indicators are, here's what I did. Let's
take rates.
Let's suppose you go back in time and
look at years in which rates dropped by
more than 1% between 0 and 1% and also
look at years where rates went up, rates
going down, rates were going up and then
look at the returns across time.
You can already see if you look at the
last column that this is a very noisy
indicator.
It's true that when rates drop between
zero and 1%,
your returns are 18.4%. Right? But
before you get too excited, when rates
drop by more than 1%, which should be
better, right? The annual return is only
9.14%.
When rates go up by 0 to 1%, your
returns are 9.84, but they go up by more
than 1%.
They're up only 6.25%.
You might look at this and say this is,
you know, this means when interest rates
go up, it's bad for stocks. And interest
rates go down, it's good for stocks.
That might be the conclusion you reach,
but you can see it's a very noisy
relationship and there are lots of
things that can cause you not to earn
the returns you see on paper. When
interest rates go down, is it good for
stocks? Perhaps. But again, this is also
I mean, I'm looking at returns in the
following year. in the same year you
might get a much stronger relationship
but because you have to observe what
happens and then invest. So I didn't
clarify that better before I described
this table. This is what you're doing
after you've observed what happened to
rates in the previous year. Knowing
what's happened to rates in the last
year doesn't help you that much
in the market in terms of forecasting
what stocks will do.
There's a study by bunch of researchers
who looked at a strategy of in of
switching from stock to cash based on
the level of the table rate. And while
they concluded that having this strategy
would have added about 2% in excess
returns before transactions, cost and
taxes,
there's a danger here of making money on
paper on these strategies because it's a
follow-up know look at the same strategy
discovered. Much of that excess return
came from one time period 1950 to 75.
You took that out all of the
predictability disappeared. So when you
look at these studies that claim to time
the entire market based on rates, take a
deeper look. You see what about the
level of rates? Aren't lower rates
better for returns than higher rates?
Well, this graph what I have is the
level of rates on one axis and what
stocks do in the other. Right? Now if
you have a strong positive rel, in other
words, when you expect when rates are
low, you expect returns to be higher.
You should expect to see that show up as
much better returns when rates are low
and you don't.
This looks like a short gun blast. In
fact, the line I fit through was at a
very slightly positive slope. In fact,
the years where T-bond rates were
higher, the returns tended to be higher
in the following year. Here again, I'm
not looking at returns by looking at the
same year. So the level of debond rates
rate you observe it and you look at what
stock returns are in the next year not
much to learn. So you tell me rates are
low now what should I do next year and
stocks I really can't tell you much
because the relationship between rates
being low or high and what stocks do in
the subsequent period
is diffuse the reason of course
intuitively is the following. If rates
are high, stock prices already reflect
those rates. For you to make returns,
stocks have to be mispriced given the
level of rates.
There are of course people argue that
T-bond rate itself is not the indicator
you should be looking. You should be
really looking at what stocks are priced
to earn which they capture with an
earnings to price ratio. The inverse of
the P ratio and compared to the T- bond
rate. It's a model called the Fed model.
It's been around for decades. There are
people who swear by it still. And what
they're looking for is an earnings yield
that exceeds the T- bond rate. So here's
what I did. I went back in time and I
broke return data down into that
different based on that difference
between the earnings yield and the T-
bond rate. So greater than 2% 1 to 2%.
So as you go further down, these are the
years where the earnings yield is less
than the T- bond rate, which at least in
the Fed model is a bad sign for stocks.
I'm going to let you make a judgment
based on the returns you see across
time, but I don't see a pattern. It's
true when earnings yield is more than 2%
higher than the T- bond rate, my returns
are 13.85%. You're saying this is great,
but your returns are almost almost as
good when the earnings yield is 1% below
the T- bond rate, which suggests again
an incredible amount of noise in this
relationship. I have never been a great
believer in the Fed model. Maybe I'm
missing some nuance here, but comparing
the earnings to price ratio, the debond
rate might give you some nice talking
points at the next cocktail party you go
to. But as a market timing device, it
hasn't worked that well. And you can cap
see that in terms of the variance in
returns over time. You think what about
the economy? So if you look at the link
between what happens to the economy
measured as the change in real GDP and
the stock return the year again it's an
incredibly noisy relationship. The
notion that when the economy is doing
well stocks do well might be widely held
but there's very little basis for it.
Stocks do well when the economy is doing
badly. Stocks can do badly when the
economy is doing well. And the reason
again is it's all relative to
expectations. Here what I've looked at
is observing what the economy is doing
and then looking at the stock return the
next year. Again the key is the reason
you don't want to look in the same year
is there's not much you will learn by
you know you can do if you learn that
when the economy is strong stocks do
well in that same year. You need to be
able to have an observable number to act
on. So what I've done is looked at um
the the data based upon GDP growth
during the year during a year from
really bad years less than 0% to really
good years and then looked at the return
in the following year. Again focus on
the average return there is no
relationship between how well or badly
the economy was doing last year and what
stocks will do in the next year. By now
you see the pattern right with every
macroeconomic indicator the linkage is
weak or often in the opposite direction
as intuition is suggest. So if your
intuition say when rates are low and the
economy is strong I should invest in
stocks hold back because the data
doesn't back that up. Second, if you
think that you can go out and forecast
macro variables, I'll concede the ground
to you because if you can forecast the
level of interest rates next year and
what GDP, maybe there's a basis for you
to make money, but forecasting macro
variables is really difficult to do.
Finally, watch out for structural
changes. We talked about interest rates
staying low in the last decade between
2010 and 2019. We also talked about why
many people attribute that the Fed or
central banks. I don't think that's the
reason why interest rates were low. You
know why rates were low in the last
decade? Because inflation dropped and
real GDP growth was anemic. Interest
rates were low for that reason. That was
a structural change. And those people
who missed that structural change ended
up being out of both the stock and the
bond market for much of the last decade
because they held their breath waiting
for rates to go back up. So to
summarize, here's what the session's
been about. Is there a linkage between
macro variables like interest rates and
the economy and markets? Obviously, but
much of that linkage is contemporaneous,
which means in years in which interest
rates go down, stock prices tend to go
up. But that's not good enough, right?
Cuz to be able to trade on something,
you got to be able to observe it. So in
this in this session, hopefully you've
seen how difficult it is to establish a
linkage between what's happened to these
fundamentals in the past and what will
happen to stocks in the future. I hope
you found the session useful and I thank
you very much for listening.